Marvel fans across the globe are celebrating
that Spider-Man won't be making an abrupt
exit from the Marvel Cinematic Universe, and
Tom Holland is right there with them.
The star of Spider-Man: Far From Home joined
much of Twitter in reacting with pure elation
to the news that Sony Pictures and Disney,
the parent company of Marvel Studios, have
reached an agreement to keep the wall-crawler
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe for one more
Spider-Man solo movie and another Marvel Studios
production.
Thousands of fans have endured more than a
month of heartbreak as Spidey's future in
the MCU has languished in limbo.
"Leave Spider-Man alone!
You gonna pick on a guy tryin' to save a bunch
of kids?"
In recent weeks, the outlook for ol' web-head's
potential return has been particularly grim.
Sony Pictures chairman and CEO Tony Vinciquerra
publicly stated that, quote, "the door is
closed" on re-upping the deal between the
two studios, and the recent news that Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige would be hopping
across the hall to produce a Star Wars movie
left many fans with the impression that he
only had time to do so because of the distinct
absence of a third Spider-Man movie.
This thankfully turned out not to be the case.
Of course, Spidey fans are thrilled.
In the immediate aftermath of the announcement
that Sony and Disney had agreed to play nice,
Twitter absolutely exploded with an outpouring
of jubilation from fans and media outlets
alike.
"Okay, Spider-Man!
Do a flip!"
"Yeah!"
"Not bad!"
CinemaBlend posted a short clip of Peter Parker
disintegrating in the arms of Tony Stark near
the end of Avengers: Infinity War, but in
reverse.
The caption?
"Mr. Stark, I feel good."
Who knew young Peter was a James Brown fan?
Another Twitter user posted fan art depicting
the famous scene from Spider-Man: Homecoming
in which Spidey attempts to keep the Staten
Island Ferry from splitting in half using
nothing but his webs, super-strength, and
sheer determination.
In the rendering, the two halves of the ferry
are marked with banners featuring the respective
logos of Sony and Disney, and the caption
reads,
"Mr. Stark…
I did it for you!!"
Of course, the name and image of Parker's
late mentor was invoked early and often in
all of the reactions.
One that really got us was a still from Avengers:
Endgame in which a dozen different emotions
are visible on Stark's face as he embraces
his young protege, who had just recently returned
from being dusted for five years.
The caption:
"WE DID IT MR.
STARK!
WE DID IT SIR!"
Another, similar still of mentor and mentee
embracing put the focus on Parker's face,
along with the caption,
"Welcome back, kid."
Yes, this stuff kind of writes itself, but
that doesn't make it any less poignant.
Some users took a slightly more subtle approach
to relaying their emotions, such as the one
who posted a short clip of Thanos finally
relaxing after accomplishing his goal of wiping
out half of all life in the universe at the
conclusion of Infinity War.
Her caption read:
"How I feel knowing that order is restored
and Spidey is back in the MCU."
Others simply felt like partying, such as
the one who asked,
"SPIDEY STANS, HOW ARE WE FEELING?"
A series of four images followed: Thor: Ragnarok
director Taika Waititi raising a glass of
wine, Holland looking like his mind has just
been blown, Hulk actor Mark Ruffalo swigging
from what appears to be a gigantic bottle
of champagne, and Holland again looking completely
blissed out in front of a background of dozens
of multicolored hearts.
Meanwhile, Holland's Far From Home co-star
Zendaya chipped in with a low-res GIF of Spidey
dancing his webs off.
But as fans expected, the single greatest
reaction to the best news they've heard in
a month came from Holland himself.
The star posted a short clip from Martin Scorsese's
The Wolf of Wall Street featuring Leonardo
DiCaprio as the notorious stockbroker Jordan
Belfort, to express his stance.
"I'm not leavin'.
I'm not leavin'.
I'm not f---in' leavin!"
And he even included fans' reaction:
Holland's post was commented upon by a bevy
of celebrities, including Ruffalo, who wrote,
"Back in a snap!
Had a feeling we would see you again."
Tony Revolori, who portrays Flash Thompson
in the Spidey solo films, commented, "Perfect!"
But perhaps the best comment of all came from
none other than Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson,
who summed up the feelings of every Spider-Man
fan on the planet today with only two words:
"F---.
Yes."
We could not have said it better ourselves.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.